حزمه عسكريه جديده ستسلمها لندن الى
القوات الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن اراضيها ضد
روسيا وطرد عناصرها من المناطق التي
احتلتها منذ بدء موسكو حمله العسكريه
العام الماضي رساله بريطانيه حملت طمانه
الشعب الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي الذي حل ضيفا في زياره خاطفه
لبيت من جهه وتحذيرا لموسكو من جهه اخرى
من المهم ان يعرف الكريم اننا سنستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل سنظل
صامدين في تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا ليس
فقط الان لاستعاده اراضيها الشرعيه ولكن
ايضا لضمان ان اوكرانيا لديها وسيله
للدفاع عن نفسها
مئات صواريخ والانظمه الدفاعيه الجويه بما
فيها طائرات بدون طيار بعيده المدى
ستوفرها الحكومه البريطانيه لاوكرانيا
وتراها لندن ضروريه في مقاومه كياف حربا
فظيعه فرضتها موسكو على
الاوكرانيينسكي ممتن للدعم البريطاني
المتواصل لبلده حتى قبل بدايه الحمله
العسكريه لكنه يضغط للحصول على الطائرات
حربيه
تحدثنا اليوم عن تزويدنا بمقاتلات والامر
مهم جدا لاننا لا نتحكم في اجواءنا وهذا
معروف كوننا شركاء حقيقيين يعرف كل تفاصيل
ما يجري في ساحه المعركه ونريد انشاء
تحالف للحصول على الطائرات الحربيه وانا
متفائل جدا في هذا الخصوص لان هناك قرارات
مهمه ستتخذ قريبا
فيما المناقشات مستمره اكد سوناك ان بلاده
ستكون جزءا من تحالف دوليا لتقديم الدعم
الذي يطالب به زيلينسكي اجتماع الزعيمين
ياتي بعد ان وافقت الحكومه البريطانيه
الاسبوع الماضي على ارسال صواريخ بعيده
المدى لاول مره الى جانب الدعم العسكري
بقيمه مليارين وثلاثه مليون جنيه تعهدت به
لندن العام الماضي
لا توجد خطط لارسال طائرات حربيه بريطانيه
لاوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع اكدت انها
ستدرب الطيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 التي لا تستخدم في سلاح الجو الملكي
والحزمه العسكريه الجديده تاكيد على
مواصله وقوف بريطانيا مع الشعب الاوكراني
وحمايه اراضيه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات